[Music]
right welcome to the up uh we're on the
gorgeous lake superior and i've gone
hunting for thimbleberry jam with the
most amazing monk and come on who
doesn't love monk jam now i'm going to
turn this jam into a stunning dessert
now these simple berries um
they go fast let me tell you it's not
the moose nipping them it's the bears if
not the bears the deer and it's not the
deer then it's the monks because they
produce the most amazing jam so i've got
these beautiful apples that are grown in
the same orchard as the thimble berries
and i'm gonna turn it into almost like a
sort of eggy bread french bread dessert
now start off with
three eggs
into a bowl
okay
give that a little whisk
just
nice and lightly
a tablespoon of sugar
mix that in make sure it doesn't become
grainy okay
and then
literally
a couple of tablespoons of heavy cream
now nice thick
rich heavy cream
from there
let that sit
now i know we're in the woods on the
edge of lake superior a little touch of
honey in there
a little touch of fresh vanilla but that
is just enough to coat the bread okay so
you can follow a recipe but you should
be cooking with your eyes and just
making sure it follows through with your
whisk too thick it makes it all cloy and
heavy nice and thin it gets the bread
nice and crispy let that set
for a moment apples look at the color of
these apples
the skin is so delicious that we're not
even gonna peel them they're so tasty
okay so just a quick chop chop them too
small they disintegrate it's a very
sweet apple
but incredibly juicy
so you get them into the pan
and sort of caramelize them
the apples are delicious oh my god
from there
into a pan first of all
we start off with our sugar
sugar in
now just wait
a minute you'll start to see that
caramelizing about a tablespoon of sugar
but watch what happens to that sugar
beautiful don't throw the apples in
there yet
now a minute later you start to see that
camel okay don't take it too dark apples
in
okay
i'm gonna beautifully
give those apples a nice toss
and we've got the sweetness coming out
the apples now and that caramel's now
getting a little bit darker but a lot
more fragrant because the skin and the
flavor of those apples is delicious now
the butter will give the apples that
nice nut brown flavor but look what's
happening
they start blistering
we start forming that caramel now it's
breaking down but look at the juice
coming out the apples so beautiful
and then finally
this is a beautiful
apple cognac
so beautiful
in
oh my lord
as that caramel starts to melt
a tablespoon of double cream
beautiful now the
small parts the apple will turn into a
bit of a puree that will thicken the
cream the can will start thinking the
cream naturally bring that back up to
the boil
and it'll have a slight crunch
left in there especially
for the bread
now bread
get your bread in there don't soak that
too long in there just literally in
and then off to the side if you soak it
in there too long
it gets too soggy you'll never get it
crispy okay so this way we move quick
from there
a touch
olive all in
get that pan nice and hot
in
a little touch of butter
beautiful
as that starts to color
in we go
first slice lay away from you
deeply done
second slice
lay away again beautifully done
and the third one
drain off any excess
and then in
don't saturate the bread
with the egg mixture otherwise it
becomes too soggy so
literally
in and out now as that's cooking
get tiny little speckles of butter
and put around the outside of the bread
this is the kind of bread that i grew up
with as a quick dessert in the uk it's
called eggy bread
and then
in france they call it french toast
god knows why because it's not toasted
however
touch of butter that gives a nice flavor
to the bread stops it becoming too sweet
okay and then we're ready for flipping
when you flip these
you're going to turn this bread once
otherwise you're going to break it
and here we go
first one
beautiful
second one in
beautiful
and then you can see the what that
beautiful butter does gives that bread
flavor
okay apples are reduced beauty down and
once the apples absorb all that cream
you've got that really nice sort of
candied almost like a toffee apple there
and now for the most exciting part okay
putting this thing together
leave them in the pan
this is where that plain jane bread goes
up a level okay
big thank you to the monks
that amazing jam
you take one out
straight on there
at the spoon
and you spread that thimbleberry jam on
beautiful
your apples
get them on there hot
and how cool is this everything's so
local
next
on she
goes again back of the spoon
thimbleberry jam
and then
finally
got that beautiful
slice generals those apples
on she goes
and then finally
a nice
little dollop creme fraiche
a teaspoon
on my jam
and then
the monks would be upset if i wasted
these apples
around she goes
and that
has to be
a delicious
amazing
thimbleberry monk jam french toast
sandwich
live
from the u.p who doesn't love monk jam
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch on catch up
on disney plus
[Music]